[Música]
Hola Bob Buen día Kelly los tulipanes se
ven muy bien Te has preguntado alguna
vez Cómo experimenta el mundo tu perro
Esto es lo que ve no muy interesante
pero lo que huele esa es una historia
muy distinta y comienza en su
maravillosamente desarrollada nariz
conforme atrapa los primeros indicios de
aire fresco la humedad del morro
esponjoso externo ayuda a captar los
aromas de la brisa la capacidad de oler
por separado por cada fosa nasal de oler
en estéreo ayuda a determinar la
dirección de la Fuente de olor Así que
en los primeros momentos de la
inhalación empieza a darse cuenta no
solo de las cosas que hay allí sino de
dónde están ubicadas
conforme entra el aire un pequeño
pliegue de tejido lo divide en dos
sectores uno para respirar y otro solo
para oler este segundo flujo de aire
entra en una zona con varios cientos de
millones de células receptoras olfativas
altamente especializadas muchas más que
nuestros cinco millones A diferencia de
nuestra respiración bidireccional por el
mismo pasaje ellos exhalan por unas
ranuras que tienen a un lado del morro
que crean remolinos de aire que atraen
nuevas moléculas de olor Y eso les
permite acumular olor en olfateos
múltiples
pero una arquitectura nasal tan
impresionante no sería de mucha ayuda
sin algo que procesara esas cargas de
información nasal
Y es que el sistema olfativo dedicado al
procesamiento de olores ocupa
relativamente mucho más espacio en el
cerebro canino que en el humano
todo esto les permite distinguir y
recordar variedades de aromas
específicos en concentraciones hasta 100
millones de veces menores que lo que
podemos detectar
si puedes oler un chorrito de perfume en
una habitación pequeña un perro podría
olerlo en un estadio cerrado y
distinguir sus ingredientes
y todo en la calle las personas o los
autos cualquier cosa en la basura del
vecino cada tipo de árbol las aves e
insectos en Ellos tienen un perfil
distinto de olor que le revela a tu
perro que es donde está y en qué
dirección se mueve además de ser mucho
más poderoso que el nuestro el Sentido
del olfato de un perro puede detectar
cosas que no se ven un sistema olfativo
separado el órgano bomeronasal encima
del paladar detecta las hormonas que
todos los animales liberan naturalmente
eso les permite identificar posibles
parejas o distinguir entre animales
amigos y hostiles les avisa de nuestros
estados emocionales e incluso puede
detectar embarazos o enfermedades
como el olfato es más primario que otros
sentidos no pasa por el tálamo y
directamente conecta con las estructuras
del cerebro encargadas de la emoción y
los instintos la percepción del perro es
inmediata y visceral pero lo más
sorprendente del olfato canino es que
puede atravesar el tiempo aparece el
pasado en las huellas de los transeúntes
y en el calor de un auto estacionado
recientemente en el residuo existente en
el lugar y en lo que has hecho
recientemente
lugares emblemáticos como hidrantes y
árboles que tienen mensajes de quienes
pasaron que comieron y cómo se sentían y
el futuro está en la brisa que alerta de
algo o alguien que sea cerca mucho antes
de verlo para cuando vemos si escuchamos
algo un perro huele una historia
completa de principio a fin en algunos
de los mejores ejemplos de colaboración
canino humano los perros nos ayudan
compartiendo y reaccionando a esas
historias pueden responder con
amabilidad a las personas en peligro o
con agresión a las amenazas ya que el
estrés y la ira forman una nube de
hormonas que su olfato reconoce con el
entrenamiento adecuado incluso nos
pueden alertar de amenazas invisibles
desde bombas hasta cáncer Pues resulta
que el mejor amigo del hombre no es el
que experimenta las mismas cosas que
nosotros sino a que el cuyo olfato
increíble revela otro mundo Más allá de
nuestra vista
si bien todos los mamíferos comparten
ciertas características una de las
diferencias más notables entre las
especies es como dan a luz Explore Los
Increíbles y a veces extraños métodos de
nacimiento de los mamíferos con este
video